قال امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين الشيخ للجزيره ان
اتفاقيه اوسلو ماتت وانتهت تحت جنازير
الدبابات الاسرائيليه وفق تعبيره مضيفا ان
التسويه السياسيه اصبحت مستحيله مع
الحكومه اليمينيه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
اوسلو انتهت تحت جنازير الدبابات
الاسرائيليه اوسلو انتهت مع استمرار
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي الذي يقتل حل
الدولتين اوسلو انتهت مع الجرائم الذي
ترتكب الان في قطاع غزه والدبابات
الاسرائيليه في قلب قطاع غزه لم يعد هناك
مكان لاسلو لذلك انا قلت ان التسويه
السياسيه تعثرت ووصلت الى طريق مسدود مع
هذه الحكومه اليمينيه وهذا يتطلب
الان وعندما تضع هذه الحرب اوزارها ان
نذهب الى تقييم وطني شامل بمشاركه الكل
الفلسطيني دون استثناء تحت مظله وطنيه
جامعه هي منظمه التح
الفلسطينيه